and happening right now as search and
rescue crew is out trying to find that
missing two-year-old toddler
thank you so much for being with us for
the news here at noon i'm alex backus
those crews have set up at twain and
paradise that's near the last place
amari nicholson was seen last week
jim mohler is there live now where crews
are passing out flyers today hi joe
hey there the family is getting really
desperate for any sort of information
related to this search some have come
from out of state to help
pass out flyers to this area just like
this and behind us here is this tent
which is for search crews they have
pictures and flyers to hand out to
people
and this is right next door to the
complex where he was last seen last
wednesday now at the time amari went
missing his mother tells me she was in
colorado
i was told he was being watched by her
boyfriend
his name is terrell rhodes rhodes says a
family member from amari's father's side
came and picked up amari
they say that never happened nevada
child seekers a non-profit that helps
families find missing children is out
here the coordinator margarita edwards
tells me they need to get more
information
[Music]
from my knowledge
that reward is now up to thirty thousand
dollars being put up by the father's
side now crews have been out at this
location throughout
uh throughout this weekend trying to get
flyers into everyone's hands now back
out here live you're taking a look at
the table with this uh where the crews
have set up there's a map there
giving some information for people who
are walking up and grabbing these flyers
to to give out to people in this
neighborhood now the family is asking
people to share this information online
so they get get the picture out there on
social media
metro says they need any information
they can get so if you have any
information that might
help find amari you're asked to call
metro we're reporting live here your
twain and paradise joe moore 8 news now